this is one of my favorite audiences I
feel that at cube con you get a mix of
folks that are interested in the high
level and also really want to know the
details and play with the technology so
today we have an agenda that's tailored
just for you I'm a Pernod Cinna I lead
product for kubernetes gke and our
anthos product today we're going to talk
about how you can use google cloud
technologies to accelerate your journey
towards enterprise transformation google
cloud has had outstanding success in
helping companies of all sizes really
modernize and move to the cloud and
every industry today is the digital
industry we're seeing technology
transform entire sectors and change the
basis for competition and I think we see
it all in our daily lives - if you think
about how you got here today whether you
use a taxi service how you educate your
children how you buy your groceries all
of that has really changed in the last
five years on a personal note my
children's school curriculum actually
runs on Google cloud and so I can say
from experience that Google cloud is
really leading this transformation and
it's not just for small companies it's
in companies that are hundreds of years
old that are looking to transform their
industry and how do we do this
we do this through cutting-edge
technology in Google cloud in particular
it's technology that enables
applications that are highly personal
that have intelligence that are agile
that are efficient and that give you
access so if you're on an IT team today
what does this mean for you I think many
of you in the audience already
experienced this but when I look at the
role of the IT team from five years ago
to today it has really changed it used
to be that IT was responsible for cost
reduction and the funny thing is that I
see is still responsible for cost
reduction but on top of that you're also
responsible for contributing to the
top-line who are responsible for
ensuring
faster time-to-market and agility and
that's not easy because you've got to do
more with less and you've got to make
sure that you get to that agility
without compromising security so when I
talk to CIOs today they say in order to
enable true speed to market I have to
have an agile platform and I have two
questions associated with that number
one how do I either build this platform
or get this platform should I buy
something off the shelf that's
enterprise ready or should I build it
from scratch and continuously maintain
it and the second question is how do i
balance my investment in existing
systems or systems on Prem and
modernizing those systems versus what
I'm using in the cloud those are the two
most pressing questions that I hear and
actually the answer to these two
questions is related in our view you've
got to pick a platform that is
consistent that actually runs both on
Prem as well as in public cloud and in
fact in multiple public clouds that's
the reality of today and so in choosing
this platform the reason that's
important is because it allows you to
maximize the investment in your talent
so you don't have to retrain your
engineers in every cloud environment and
ultimately building this platform
yourself is not a great idea because it
takes a lot of top talented engineers to
build such a thing those engineers could
be better utilized actually contributing
to business differentiating capability
this is why earlier this year Google
Cloud introduced anthos anthos is a
modernization platform it's meant for
you to develop applications and run them
anywhere and it's a platform that's very
flexible it can run in your on-prem
environment it can run in Google Cloud
it can run in other clouds and it can
also run at the edge in your branch
locations in retail stores even in
stadiums what's unique about anthos
things number one that it's
software-based most people that I talk
to already have quite a bit of hardware
they've perhaps chosen a hardware vendor
that they're working with
they've got contracts in place or in
some of the edge locations there's a lot
of constraints in terms of what the
footprint is so having a software
platform means that you have flexibility
you can purchase new hardware if you
choose to or you can try and reuse what
you already have the second unique
capability is that it's built on open
source it's open but it's opinionated
and the opinionation is actually really
important it means that with anthos
we're building in all that google has
learned about how to run an SRE function
how to manage applications at scale how
to do container management that's part
of the platform open means that it's
portable but it's not so hard to manage
and then lastly it abstracts the
infrastructure so that your folks can
actually focus on business innovation
and that last part is something that we
learned from our experience would gke I
think many of the folks in the crowd
today have used UK perhaps we can have a
show of hands how many you've used UK
yeah about 80% of the audience that's
quite good
so gke was introduced five years ago
actually in November we're celebrating
the fifth birthday of gke and it has
seen incredible success you can see you
know we've got a lot of users across
industries and of various sizes it's top
rated by analysts and it's been
acknowledged by customers I think the
most important thing here has been the
success that gke has enabled for its
customers and the type of applications
that they've built for example eBay has
built a shop bot that enables
personalized shopping on their mobile
app Pizza Hut enables faster delivery of
pizzas to you during Super Bowl and also
during any regular day but these are
things that as a product leave it's
really
heartwarming to see our customers
implement changes that affect our lives
everyday and why is that possible that's
possible because even though they're
using kubernetes they're not actually
managing the kubernetes gke is taking
away a lot of the toil so that they can
focus on building new experiences for
their end-users that's the key learning
how did we do this we did this actually
by abstracting the infrastructure and
automating more and more capabilities
over the last five years we started by
managing the the control plane and then
providing auto repair auto scaling and
auto management of the nodes and then we
saw that actually it was really helpful
to our users so then we added additional
capabilities like auto scaling of GPUs
and the result was that machine learning
workloads took off on gke so as we add
more automation we see more and more
usage we've now added four-way auto
scaling so you can vertically auto scale
your pods you can also auto provision so
you don't have to worry about the
efficiency of your cluster it
automatically takes care to make sure
that you're running in the most
efficient manner and we're not stopping
there this list on the left-hand side is
just the number of new capabilities
added to GK in the last two months here
you see that we're making the platform
more secure through container native
networking we're making it more reliable
especially upgrades I think earlier
today someone mentioned hey what are we
doing to improve upgrades we're making
them more reliable through a number of
features one of which is called surge
upgrades and other capability is release
channels which allows you to choose your
level of innovation how much of a
cutting-edge release you want to use
versus stability and then in terms of
agility we've been adding many more
workloads today 60% of workloads on gke
are stateful that's databases and batch
workloads and we're adding support for
Windows which is moving to beta this
week and also
batch workloads so what we learn from
this experience is that it's truly
important to give users choice but that
choice should come with opinionation and
management in order to be adoptable
that's the bound that's the foundation
on which anthos is building anthos is
taking that gke core and bringing it to
the on-prem environment as well as to
other clouds but it's very much tailored
towards the enterprise and the CIO we
take the manage platform and we add
several layers on top
first of all in an enterprising
environment you need centralized policy
and configuration management so that's a
key element it's at the heart of the
anthos control plan secondly with many
services across environments in your
cloud you need service management and
that's something that comes out of the
box with anthos and then most
importantly in order to make the
developers productive you need a
seamless developer experience and that's
something that we're enabling with cloud
run on anthos so I'm gonna try and give
you a whirlwind tour of the capabilities
of anthos but the whole day is devoted
to going through these in detail so this
will just be a quick one here I'm gonna
cover five unique aspects of the
platform first how do you get started
is it a forklift or is it easy to get
started with second now that you've
started with it how do you make sure
that it's secure third how can you make
those developers productive force what
about your legacy applications and then
lastly how do you operate at scale so
let's get into it
athos is not a rip and replace platform
no matter where you are in your journey
you can get started easily and to enable
that we have this capability so you can
bring your own clusters to ant those and
we're going to demo that later today but
it's already in beta and many customers
are using it what that means is that if
you have a kubernetes cluster somewhere
and most enterprises have kubernetes
somewhere at this point if it's a
conformant cluster you can connect it up
to the anthos control plane
can get a single pane of glass for
visibility as well as for workload
management if you don't have a cluster
it's as many of you know it's easy to
get started with gke you can start a
cluster in less than 5 minutes and then
it's part of the anthos control plan or
you can use gk on Prem our anthos on
Prem offering and bring that to the
cloud if you have no containerized
applications at all we'll talk about
later today you can migrate existing VM
based applications into anthos as well
so there are many ways to getting
started and it doesn't have to be a lift
and shift or a forklift seconds once you
get started how do you make sure that
the environment is secure anthos has a
number of capabilities built in to
ensure security by default there's
actually a long list but some of the
ones that I'd like to cover and show in
this in this animated gif anthos brings
the ability to have consistent security
and configuration enabled from a single
source of truth typically this is a git
repo you set your policies in the git
repo and these are policies that could
be security policies related to your
mesh they could be our back policies
related to kubernetes or quota policies
and from the single source of truth
these policies are distributed to all of
the enrolled clusters and then enforced
what this gift shows is an add those
policy controller this controller checks
all of the access to any API in your
cluster and make sure that it complies
with the enterprise policies that you've
set that's just one of the controls
there's also security controls built
into the service mesh and then lastly
anthos comes with binary authorization
which enables you to define security tap
checks upstream in the development
process making sure that only validated
verified images are integrated into your
build and release process security is
not just for security sake
security is what actually enables
development to go faster because it
doesn't stand in the way
so once you've made a secure environment
and you've brought your environment into
anthos then comes the most important
task which is building applications so
how do we make that easier there's two
ways first anthos comes with a
kubernetes application marketplace that
makes it really easy to procure
applications that are already tested and
available from both first party and
third party providers this gif is
showing you cloudBees if you want to
deploy cloudBees it's actually a single
click deployment from the anthos
marketplace and you can choose which
cluster you want to deploy to it can be
any of the clusters that are enrolled
including on-prem clusters or clusters
in other clouds and this service is
supported by the partner in this case
cloudBees and comes with integrated
billing from google cloud this is of
course if you want to reuse existing
services what about the most important
piece which is your own services that
your developers will build and that's
where the easy application development
experience of anthos and cloud run comes
in so this is showing you how you can
take a container image and deploy it
into a cluster and have an internet
exposed application in less than a
minute it's an extremely simple user
experience it works for clusters in
Google cloud it also works now for
clusters on Prem the fourth aspect
you've got your cloud native
applications but what about your legacy
applications and that's where my great
four anthos comes in this is actually
brand new technology it's quite
differentiated it doesn't exist anywhere
else and what it does is it takes
existing monolithic workloads that are
residing in VMs that could be in VMware
VMs or they could be in VMs in another
cloud and it automatically migrates
those to those applications into a
stateful set in kubernetes and brings it
into the anthos environment there are
certain benefits of doing this
it's not a magic solution it doesn't get
you a microservices it's still a
monolith but the benefits of doing this
is that one it's a lot easier to get in
and secondly it actually does give you
the advantages of bin packing so you get
a more efficient environment where
you're using your monolith in a more
effective way
usually the efficiency is from such a
migration actually pay for the migration
itself and finally once you have these
applications into anthos how do you
manage them at scale
that's the fifth part and that is what
we enable with service management and
the service management this is really
built upon the best practices that we
found within Google through our sre
function the service graph essentially
is an ad a glance view of all the
services in your environment it gives
you a hierarchical picture where you can
drill down into the resources and you
can see the relationships between the
services you can see the traffic flow
between the services and monitor various
important metrics like the latency and
you can set s ellos on those metrics to
see when there are violations and also
policies to remediate these are some of
the best practices that we have learned
through management of many micro
services in our environment and we found
that the largest customers in gke have
in fact many many services and this
becomes a necessity at that point so
those are the five kind of core pillars
of anthos that we're going to walk
through in detail today each of the
sessions later today we'll go in and
show you the technology show you what
the what the capabilities are in the
form of an actual demo and you'll have a
chance to ask the engineering team and
the product team questions afterwards in
order to implement a transformation in
an enterprise we found that it's not
enough to just cater to the needs of
developers or to the needs of the
platform team
that's why anthos has so many different
capabilities something that caters to
each role in the organization for the
platform engineering team easy tools to
help them
manage the operations environment for
the developers integration with with
their IDE s and the ability to choose
from the marketplace or build an
application in a server list fashion for
service operators all the goodness of
the s re tooling and then of course for
security and compliance built-in
capability and we're finding that our
customers are finding a lot of value
from this some of our financial services
customers are improving their agility by
13x we've also found you know in the
most traditional of industries a company
like Airbus being able to use serverless
technology in their own Prem and cloud
environment this is truly
revolutionizing their their work and in
order to enable it we've got an
ecosystem of partners for anthos at
different layers in the marketplace we
have technology partners increasingly
more and more enterprise applications
are being containerized and made
available in the marketplace for you to
use directly in terms of platform
partners Cisco HP and Dell have provided
reference architectures should you want
to buy new hardware you can couple that
with anthos and then several of our
service partners some of whom are even
here today are available to assist with
the migration process anthems is really
enabling new business opportunities you
saw several examples today in financial
services in retail in Health Sciences
customers are using these capabilities
to bring new experiences HSBC for
example is enabling a transformation in
banking to reach their customers more
easily in retail and commerce
particularly with the edge you're seeing
much more innovation happening with the
retail season and then lastly in
healthcare we have companies that are
using AI to improve the drug discovery
process the question is really what will
all of you do with this platform and I
think that is what we hope to inspire
today through the discussion thank you
you